[Musique]
il s'appelait yannick baptiste
mayol
à lima
oda
fabián
amateurs de rock ou de musique classique
des artistes des juristes des créatifs
des bourguignons dont on a volé la vie
un vendredi soir dans les rues de paris
yannick maviel un jeune publicitaire de
39 en partie d'epervans en saône et
loire pour construire sa vie à paris un
père tendre et attentionné
décédé dans une salle de concert
comme fabián stech
ce professeur d'allemand dans un lycée
de dijon s'étaient offert une escapade
dans la capitale pour venir voir jouer
son groupe fétiche
fabienne c'était la joie de ses élèves
et de ses collègues
il a un charisme extraordinaire il avait
pardon un charisme extraordinaire si
bien qu'il était fédérateur à sa façon
et tout le monde est prêt à le suivre
tous les gens qui sont ici germanistes
ou pas le connaissait forcément on
entendait parler d'une classe à l'autre
on entend des rires d'une classe à
l'autre avec cette voix grave et stature
qu'il avait qui faisait de lui un être
inévitable
les visages de celles et ceux qui
savourait la vie michael guibert
vivaient des débuts prometteurs dans une
carrière de juriste un jeune homme qui
avait grandi à mort et près de chalon
dans la presse sa soeur anaïs évoque un
mec bien
baptiste chevreau 24 ans voulait percer
dans le milieu de la musique comme sa
grand mère la chanteuse à texte anne
sylvestre
à tonnerre où il était né ses parents
redonner vie à son lieu fétiche un
kiosque à musique c'était son lieu un de
ces lieux dans lequel il venait quand il
était au lycée et aussi même par la
suite il est venu quand il revenait le
week-end nice vous donner rendez vous
ici ça permet aussi que son nom soit pas
juste sur sa pierre tombale
et puis celles qui sont tombés sous les
balles à la terrasse du café la belle
équipe halima et hoda saadi deux soeurs
originaire du creusot elle fêtait ce
soir-là l'anniversaire dauda à l'image
jeune mère de famille est décédée sur le
coup oda des suites de ses blessures
une douleur incommensurable pour leur
frère béchir saadi
une schéma
qui nous a laissé deux enfants edf a
déjà deux enfants donc nous a laissé un
petit bout d'os un petit coup d'oeil à
farako s'en occupe et je n'ai jamais
notre soeur roda que je n'oublierai
jamais
continuer de vivre tenter de se
reconstruire
c'est le défi de gaëtan honoré
le soir du 13 novembre ce professeur de
nevers a survécu caché dans la fosse du
bataclan on est entouré de deux cadavres
de deux choses complètement mais qu'on
ne croyait pas possible mais malgré tout
on se dit non mais moi j'ai pas assez vu
mes filles je les ai pas s'embrasser à
midi ma femme m'a tant j'ai encore plein
de choses à faire crû en novembre
dernier nous avions accompagné gates ont
honoré à paris
un rescapé déterminée a raconté ce
fameux soir d'automne
je n'ai pas réfléchi cette une autre une
autre possibilité il fallait que je
puisse témoigner à la barre devant la
cour
décrire ce mal féroce qui le dévore
encore huit ans après
témoigner pour ceux qui ne peuvent plus
le faire